would you ever date a man who makes much
less than you
no
it's not happening
well i'm a teacher so i make no money so
probably no
absolutely not yeah i don't think money
is like the big issue like personally
for me like i want to have like a super
big income and successful but doesn't
really matter for the guy i don't think
so i like to be with someone that it
could be financially stable and help me
to grow yes
yeah yeah i think are you sure about
that
i think so yes would i do it again
probably not i think i've learned
that was your friend by the way yeah um
i retract that statement because i was
drinking a lot of
okay because what i was about to say is
every single girl when i asked
would you date a guy who makes less than
you no no i was nervous to go on that
and then little victoria's like yeah
yeah well i guess so i want to make
i mean but you know how they say you
know
tequila exactly once all right once you
start drinking the tequila truth comes
exactly the truth starts coming out
a lot i did it a lot of like guys who
didn't make money okay well how's that
worked out i'm being serious here look
at me no no stop it i'm not you're not
going to play the victim here you're too
good of a girl um
but you dated a broker they i dated a
broke out but they had like a drive to
like they were working on themselves
like they were driving they're ambitious
yeah they were working on like they were
like working on their like whole brand
and like building themselves so like i'm
not going to judge them as they where
they were at the moment
but once they stopped working on like
it's when you're broke and you're
complacent too i'm just like okay so
what you doing like are you working
towards your goal like where are you at
because everyone's got to start
somewhere so i can't like judge someone
on their journey yeah and especially if
we have got young people watching 21 22
23 like they're just getting their
career started
hey i was the brokest one of my friends
until i actually
started actually getting serious about
my future and my income like it took me
until i was 27 i was
proudly like yeah i'm the couch guy you
know you got to see someone serious
about like going further i mean there's
been a time where i've like been
completely broke had zero dollars in my
bank account and like but i was still
like had this drive and i was still
going i was still hustling i was still
moving and if i see a guy who you know
maybe doesn't have as much money as me
but he's hustling he's moving and i can
see he has like okay that's his goal
like he's going to it that's hot to me
yeah well basically what i'm what i was
getting at is that
ambition women are attracted to
confidence and ambition
yes absolutely so even if you're young
and you're like
i don't have a lot of money which we all
were there when we were in our early 20s
you could as a woman you could tell the
guy that's like damn i'm i'm working you
they're getting up they're working
they're driving they have ambition you
can tell rather than the guy who's just
taking bong hits every day and just i
don't know i'll figure it out bro there
is a difference yes there's a difference
yeah okay there's a difference but back
to this question there's no way you
would date a guy who made much less than
you nope not even gonna happen you've
had that bad experience never again
would you date a woman that made much
less than you hypothetical question yeah
absolutely yeah okay i mean it's you
know i'm again like i'm pretty
independent i'm very someone that's just
wants to like i like i think as men we
like to provide like that same with like
them
whatever roles that they want to play i
think that whatever fulfills you in the
relationship is really what you should
be focusing on and again the line of
communication like what is it do you
want to do what do you like to do what
fulfills you and don't force something
to happen just because maybe society
wants you to like if it's the back ass
ass backwards like if you wanted to um
for example
a woman was like oh i don't care if a
guy makes no money as long as the guy
can handle
the power
uh you know the shift because that's
where i see that could be an issue i
could see the guy being like well i
don't feel like a man so i can't handle
this or you can get a guy that's just
like i'm perfectly fine with it i think
it's rare for something like that
like very rare but for me
i like to you know i like to provide i
think that gives me purpose yeah you
want to respond to that i love it i i
mean i i think he nailed it i think uh a
masculine man a good man he wants to
provide
you know and he wants his woman to feel
safe and it doesn't matter how much how
successful she is he wants to make sure
that um that he honors her you know so i
i mean as a woman when i'm when when i'm
with a man i honor him and i'm expecting
for him to do the same to me
yep you just honor in different ways
thoughts on that victoria
i agree
i mean i agree like i want the man to
provide like even though my mom and dad
were
both wildly successful whatever
with both what they did respectfully
um my dad was always the provider in the
situation my mom just could you know
afford to go shopping with her own money
but like my dad was always the provider
and even in the relationships where i
knew the guy made a little less than me
like he still took me out to dinner like
he still tried and i think i was like
hey i admire that and why he's hustling
so i think i mean there's a lot of
respect because people can't expect
someone i mean it's rare now like you
just come out of the gate and you're
rich unless you have a trust fund so no
that's not and that's i don't think
anybody expects and like you know and
dating you can't expect like i think a
lot of women need to expect like guys
are just not automatically rich they got
to work for it too so like i appreciate
when a guy is like hustling and working
just as hard as i am yeah our friend
rolo uh author of the rational male
intersexual dynamics he says that
um women are
and men must become
do you know what that means
like women like he gave a story i don't
know who it was um there was andrew tate
actually and he said
i was on a yacht billionaire's lot right
and it was on there it was a hundred
women this is andrew tate um and and
there were four dudes
four dudes
and a hundred women
do you know what those [ __ ] four
dudes had to do to get on that yacht
so true did you know how much money they
had to make and how much influence they
had to make and how much they had to
contribute decide just to be on that
yacht with those 100 women and what did
those 100 women have to do
buy some [ __ ] lipstick
and that's the difference but when they
say
women are and men must become
um men must become but again i got that
clarity for a man it's harder to do it's
harder to become but at least you know
you need to so if you like that clip
click right here to watch another or if
you want to watch the entire sauce cast
click right here
[Music]